hey guys this is the just pearly things
youtube channel and i
am hannah pearl today i am going to be
reacting to different rap videos
i'm someone i swear to god i don't
really listen to rap and if i do
it's like the mainstream like kanye
drake whatever
so today i was recommended to listen to
the song
by pooh sheisty
back in blood featuring little dirk
yeah so i'm just gonna listen and give
you my interpretation of the lyrics i
don't it might be right it might be
wrong
don't forget before i go comment like
subscribe
let me know if i'm like close on the
lyrics like
if my interpretation's right or wrong i
think i'm getting better
[Music]
honestly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i gotta hear this again i was
having a okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this is what i think is
happening so it sounds like he's going
to like a club
of some sort i don't i don't know what's
going on in the club
but it sounds like these people thought
they were like
thugs so i learned in the last video
that thug's a good thing
so i think thug there's like a comment
that said if you're thug it just means
you're not like afraid of stuff
and you're cool i don't know but because
um so he's saying like all these people
are talking
but like if you're a thug you do more
than talk
so you say i thought you were a thug and
he's saying you're not a thug
[Music]
okay so i'm a little confused by this so
like
like it sounds like he's saying to get
it in blood
which i mean like is that like kill
somebody like
listen to this part again
okay i think i get it so someone i think
his group maybe killed someone in their
group
and then like he's saying like you know
who did it come get it back in blood i
thought you were a thug
you're talking but you're not doing
anything so
we're gonna find out
[Music]
okay i'm like actually i have to listen
to it again
okay so they're mentioning a glock here
which is like a gun
so i think he's saying like that there
is like like he still is 15 in the glock
which is probably like
15 bullets um
i'm gonna just keep going because i was
really confused by that part there were
some guns
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so he's saying like if you got it
in blood
i don't care where we were and then okay
my other thing is
why do rappers like with as soon as they
get
money they like throw it around like
that's not safe people could just steal
it from you
you what you should do is put it like in
investments
you know like a savings like emergency
fund but they just like
throw it up that's not a good investment
strategy honestly like
he just keeps saying and like i feel
like there's a lot of people dying in
this but i don't really know like
for what and i think the general message
is like
you say you're a thug but you're not a
thug
[Music]
[ __ ]
okay now i'm thinking that maybe they
took
stuff like they stole it now that i'm
hearing the chorus again so just
basically say okay i'm getting it now
i go to the club i don't need security
because i hold guns
and um
yeah so i don't need security i hold
guns you guys talk
you know i took your [ __ ] come get it
back and kill me
but he's saying they won't because
you're a wolf so like you talk
but you don't do anything maybe or like
that that's something
that was so much so
it sounds like like he's someone's
talking [ __ ] like i feel like the whole
theme of this song
is i'm talking like someone's talking
[ __ ]
sounds like he said some bad things
about the cousin
and the conflict resolution here is just
get it in blood this is where i'm
confused though because like honestly
if someone's talking [ __ ] just don't
deal with them again why are we why are
we talking about guns like this
is a little dramatic like for me
one click
okay here's one thing i don't understand
like look at
if you look at the video there's so many
people in it like how do you have this
many friends like
i'm sure you're a charismatic guy you
know i'm sure
but like i don't have that many friends
and do they all just throw around the
money it like just probably
from like a probability standpoint like
how many of them
actually have money and again why don't
they put the money in a bank account
like it just doesn't make sense to me
[Music]
[Music]
production
okay like i feel like i'm just repeating
myself
because honestly like i just feel like
something's going on someone took
something and he's saying like
i don't need security because i have
guns
and if you want your [ __ ]
come get it back like in blood
so like which is like
come kill me for it and he's mad that
everyone's talking [ __ ]
i don't know how accurate this is i
think i got it right
i think i did pretty good so if you
think i got it right comment below
what you think i got right well you
think i got wrong
i don't know i think i was a1 this time
if you want to
see more of these videos let me know too
and also let me know
what song i should do next because i
need suggestions